je suis très ravi de te voir comme si
cela ne s'est pas et mon animateurs
préférés
là on l'allumé mission je pars avec
mireille juste d'une chose oui monsieur
petit bisou je viens du mans oui du
moment celle mensuel bien sûr c'est
qu'il le manche et les trois enfants les
enfants leur faire un petit bisou coca
liane des mines 9 ans qu'elle y en a qu
à liane salut qu'à lienz chef un gros
bisou au jury pensine victorine francine
des taurine et jean-marie n'doumi
jean-marie notre jean marie et jean
marie il a deux ans la prochaine fois tu
vas venir la prochaine fois oui est ce
que tu veux venir la semaine prochaine
moi je vais te chronique plus moi
d'accord alors déjà tu vas faire jury de
danse est l'air mal on va voir déjà ce
que tu vaux d'accord semaine prochaine
c'est ce que je vais faire je vais est
invité mme avec les enfants d'accord
c'est super d'accord le monde et
d'empocher un ancien admettre que sa
voiture c'est pas vrai mais à coude ce
que sa matière il va talent était
contente est allé raimu très c'est vrai
match je te fais un bisou ma chérie ce
très content d'avoir choisi ma chérie
qu'est ce qui se passe mon père n'en
reviens pas ma chérie pas super mais des
gueule de con comme moi ton reverra
canal moi je suis content de t'avoir
soin de toi c'est le voisin et arrête de
pleurer parce que là tu vas voir de la
danse
non franchement c'est vraiment un amour
ça me fait très plaisir et la scène
fashion show invitant chacun près mais
voilà et ben tu vois on y verra peut
être installé est avec nous je t'aime